Interesting times
for white people.
I've been observing you,
I see what's going on.
You're trying really hard
to be nice to minorities,
in a way I've never seen before.
Putting in the time.
Putting in the effort,
getting out there.
Watching Crazy Rich Asians.
White people went in droves!
Very cool.
Any white people here
see Crazy Rich Asians?
Raise your hands, anybody, yeah?
Yeah?
You, ma'am in the front,
you saw it?
Yeah, it had like a 97%
on Rotten Tomatoes.
You think it was that good, 97%?
Maybe a little less?
What number would you give it?
Eighty-five.
Eighty-five, wow.
Twelve percent less.
Anything in particular
you didn't like,
that made you dock it 12 points,
ma'am?
Are you nervous right now?
I'm just messing with you,
it doesn't matter what
you think about the movie.
It's just fun to make white
people feel bad, and--
This is so adorable,
look how far we've come.
In just two generations, right?
Like, your grandma
doesn't even call it
that movie Crazy Rich Asians.
She calls it that movie
that has too many Orientals,
and now you're sitting here,
like,
"Uh, 85%, shit,
I take it back, 97%.
What do I need to say
to not get in trouble?"
It's coming from a good place,
but some people are acting weird,
man.
I asked this one lady,
I was like,
"You see Crazy Rich Asians?"
She's like, "Yeah!"
I was like, "You like it?"
She's like, "I actually didn't
see it, I'm sorry."
I'm like,
"What are you lying for?
What did you think? I was gonna
give you some cookies?"
My favorite thing,
though, one time,
I asked someone, I was like,
"You like Crazy Rich Asians?"
They're like,
"You know what Aziz,
I'm gonna be honest with you.
First time I saw it,
I didn't really enjoy it.
But then I watched again,
with one of my Asian friends,
and I saw how much
it meant to her
to see herself represented
on the screen,
and that made me really
like the film."
And I said, "Oh, um, that doesn't
mean you like the movie.
That's just a weird,
condescending,
shitty thing to say."
Could you imagine if I watched
Paul Blart: Mall Cop?
And I was like,
"I didn't really like it,
but then I watched it again
with one of my one of
my chubby white friends...
really changed my perspective!"